based on real events a group of people
who have spent most of their lives
unable to move suddenly begin to wake up
thanks to a new treatment but it doesn't
last forever as they only have a few
days to enjoy life before returning to
their perpetual sleep
so today on cinema recapped i'll show
you
awakenings
the film begins with a group of children
enjoying an afternoon walk
one of them takes a break to engrave his
name on a bench as we see him start to
lose control of his hand a few days pass
and the child continues to have problems
controlling his body although he still
leads a normal life and goes to school
we see that he is a child with very good
grades and the teacher realizes that he
can no longer write correctly
one day he stops going to class due to
his condition
and several years later we see a doctor
played by robin williams who applies as
a neurologist
we see that he will have to work with
several people who cannot move and
others with serious mental problems who
end up overwhelming him on his first day
at work a nurse tells him that things
will get better he begins to work with
the lady who cannot move at all who
doesn't even seem to hear him he starts
to write that this person has dementia
as if it were a verdict but then he
realizes that the woman can catch his
glasses when they were about to fall he
tries to explain his discovery to the
other doctors who say it is only a
natural body reflex although he insists
that it is the will of the patient that
accomplishes it however he fails to
convince them he seems disappointed but
a nurse says that she does believe his
theory so he gets cheered up he has to
continue treating patients with other
conditions but still takes his time to
investigate more patients who cannot
move their body he sees his patients
standing up and as he removes obstacles
from in front of her he discovers that
she walks forward alone however at one
point she stops the doctor does not know
why and then he looks at another patient
of his named leonard played by robert de
niro who is the boy we saw at the
beginning the mother of this patient
explains to the doctor that her son does
not speak
but he communicates with her in other
ways although the doctor does not
understand how
that night the doctor has an idea and
returns to the hospital to further
investigate realizing that all those
patients fell into the state of lethargy
at the same year later the doctor sees a
girl playing hopscotch and he realizes
that his female patient did not continue
advancing in the room because there was
a cut in the checkered pattern floor and
when they fill it in they realize that
the patient manages to walk to a window
then the doctor investigates a life of
his other patient leonard
his mother explains that when he was a
child his condition gradually worsened
until he could no longer move or speak
he asked her what leonard liked and she
replies that he loved reading the next
day the doctor runs some studies on the
patient and shows the results to the
other doctors to whom he shows that
leonardo's brain reacted when he called
them by his name he continues to work
with the other patients when he gathers
together and teaches them to play ball
with each other another day he plays
opera music and the patient reacts to it
another nurse discovers that each
patient reacts to their favorite music
and thus more people join who help him
in his research one day the doctor uses
a ouija board to communicate with
leonard
at first he wants to teach him how to
spell but leonard selects the letters he
wants forming the title of a book that
the doctor later reads then he asks the
nurse about a drug used for parkinson's
patients a drug called aldoba
he investigates more about it with an
expert in this drug who tells him that
he is a chemist and he is a doctor so if
he wants to test that on his patients he
will be the one who should put them at
risk his boss does not believe there is
a relationship between parkinson's a
disease that makes it difficult to move
the body and the other patients who have
not moved at all for years but the
doctor convinces him however to try it
on a patient he must obtain the
authorization of a relative so he
returns to visit leonard's mother he
explains that if all goes well he can
bring his son back to life as he was
before thereby convincing her to sign
they start to administer the medicine
and juice but don't get any reaction
the doctor wants to try a higher dose
but the mother is not very hopeful that
it will work that night the doctor
decides to break the rules and give him
a much higher dose than approved
and when he wakes up he realizes that
leonard is no longer in his bed he goes
to look for him and finds him sitting in
the recreation room where he can move
around on his own leonard smiles and
even talks to him and we see that the
first thing he did is write his name
like he used to do when he was a child
in the morning leonard looks around the
hospital and then receives a visit from
his mother when he approaches to give a
hug while calling out mom all the nurses
introduce himself to leonard for the
first time
and he is very courteous to them all
later he is even able to eat on his own
and the doctor helps him improve his
mobility then leonard becomes scared
when he sees his own face because he
realizes that he is already an adult
and at night he gets scared again and
doesn't want to go to sleep in fear that
he'll wake up and not be able to move
again
but his mother calms him down and begins
to sink to him until he falls asleep the
next day leonard is comfortable with his
own image he even combs his hair and
shaves by himself he also returns to the
habit of reading he gets handsome and
they take him out of the hospital taking
them for a car ride he is happy as he
recognizes his school and many changes
in popular culture
such as music and people's clothing
which is strange to him the doctor buys
ice cream and leonard eats it on the
same bench where he engraved his name 30
years ago
after that leonard goes into the water
and even though the doctor doesn't think
he's ready for it we see him climb on a
rock to finally enjoy being alive the
doctor takes him home where leonard
notices that he is not married he
replies that he's not very good with
women although he does like them and
leonard says that he knows he likes a
hospital nurse named eleanor upon
returning to the hospital his boss tells
him that they cannot continue this
treatment for long as it is very
expensive
the doctor believes that he can convince
donors at the hospital to give more
money if they found out about leonard's
case the boss says he overestimates the
effect leonard has on people
but then he sees that even the hospital
nurses are willing to help
then the doctor convinces more people to
join the motion showing them leonard's
story
thereby raising enough money to apply
the treatment to all the other patients
and the great miracle happens one more
time we see how all the people who had
not been able to move in years get up
from their beds and rediscover the world
surprised that they have awakened from
their lathargy leonard celebrates this
achievement with a smile and in the
morning we see that the nurses have a
hard time managing all the new patients
one patient believes that everything she
lived through was just a dream another
wants to put makeup on and dye her hair
another wants to eat a good steak and in
general all patients are happy simply to
be alive although they are not even
aware what year it is one of the
patients even meets her boyfriend again
and then the doctor organizes an outing
with all the patients although leonard
does not want to go because he sees a
pretty girl at the hospital suddenly
leonard also worries a lot about his
hairstyle and tells the doctor that he
wants to stay in the hospital
there he approaches the pretty girl who
asks if he is following her
he explains that he is a patient
although she doesn't believe him since
he looks healthy while the other
patients are having fun dancing the
pretty girl talks about her life to
leonard telling him that she visits her
father who is never conscious
although sometimes it seems that he is
leonard explains to her that he used to
be the same way one of the patients
asked the doctor to dance
who gets very nervous but accepts anyway
at the same time leonard has to say
goodbye to the pretty girl
he tells her that even though her father
doesn't react he is aware that she
visits him that she loves him another
patient receives the news that her
husband divorced her while she was in
lethargy she responds thank god
meanwhile a man says that he lost his
entire family and now feels old the
pretty girl returns to visit leonard and
his mother is upset saying that her son
had never loved another woman in his
life other than her one night leonard
wakes the doctor up telling him that
after watching the news he realized that
people forgot how to live since they
don't enjoy freedom and other basic
aspects such as the value of friendship
later leonard calls a round table
discussion
where he says that he wants to be able
to leave the hospital whenever he wants
alone since he never committed any crime
or represents a risk to anyone he says
he wants to go out walk talk to people
all the things that ordinary people are
so used to that they no longer even
enjoy them and the doctors tell him that
they will take this into consideration
however later on the doctor tells him
that they decided not to approve his
request
and that he himself does not agree to do
so so they must still have him under
observation
at this leonard gets angry and says that
he will go for a walk by himself whether
they like it or not but the doctor
caused security to prevent him from
leaving so leonard ends up with tears
for not being able to be free the mother
says that he had never been this
disobedient as a child while we see
leonard trying to riot with other
patients but also he begins to have
movement problems while giving his
speech
the boss says that leonard's anger may
be due to his mental problems although
the doctor defends him saying that he
behaves like this because he took him
out of his mental confinement to detain
him in another confinement within the
hospital then he goes to talk to leonard
who has other patients as his personal
guards leonardo allows him to pass and
the doctor sees that his movement
problems are getting worse however
leonard says that he is the one with the
problem since although he has always
been alive and conscious he has never
worried about having a life or getting
married the doctor warns him that if he
continues to be rude the other doctors
may suspend his medication but leonard
still very angrily pushes him that night
leonard regrets his actions and even
fixes the glasses that the doctor broke
with the fall and in the morning his
condition has worsened so much
that he asked the doctor to help him
stand up they realized that the
medication only had a temporary effect
on leonard as he is returning to his
state of prostration even though they
haven't stopped giving him his medicine
and other patients worry the same thing
will happen to them a patient named lucy
who sings beautifully says that she is
already aware that she is not in her
time
and that she still misses it anyway
leonard is scared to return to his
previous state the doctor continues with
his medication and leonard explains that
while he was in lathargy he felt as if
he were dead and we see that he can no
longer even brush his teeth then one day
leonard begins to feel very bad and
asked to be recorded so that there is
evidence of his symptoms for future
research
the doctor increases his dose more and
more while leonard is sad because he can
no longer even read he believes that he
is failing everyone by not being able to
overcome his illness even though the
doctor tells him that he is not
leonard's mother says that her son's
suffering should be stopped as the
medicine no longer fully works on him
regardless of the dose the doctor
replies that her son is fighting to
overcome this illness but the mother
replies that he is losing the battle
leonard has a hard time getting handsome
but he succeeds and goes to eat with the
pretty girl
she finds him shaky
but she treats him with respect although
he can barely speak leonard manages to
tell her that he will no longer be able
to see her and tries to leave
but then the pretty girl takes his hand
and begins to dance with him which calms
the unarts tremors that afternoon
leonard walks with difficulty to the
window to see his beloved leave at night
he tries to draw but he cannot control
his hand anymore and that same night he
has to wear diapers again the doctor
watches the videos from when leonard had
first recovered
he says how could people call them kind
if he brought leonard back to life only
to take it away again shortly after the
nurse says that life is given to and
taken from everyone in the world and
then we see that after leonard the other
patients also followed his footsteps
back into lethargy the doctor continues
to preach leonard's legacy of enjoying
the basics in life as we see that the
nurses adjusted to what their patients
liked even after they returned to their
lathargy and that the pretty girl
continued to visit leonard to read books
to him the doctor wrote a novel based on
that experience the same one you can
find in real life under the name
awakenings and the doctor learned
leonard's lesson because he suddenly
dared to ask out the nurse he liked a
text on the screen explains that the
doctor and his team experimented trying
more substances with the patients
achieving small awakenings but none as
great as the one summer of 1969 but the
doctor did not stop communicating with
his patients for this reason as we see
he spoke to leonard again through the
ouija board
the end
if you liked the video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
recaps of the best drama movies my name
is tc and i'll see you in the next video
bye bye